and finally new rules stop telling me
every time you find evidence there might
be life on Mars until the rover pans to
the left and there are little green men
doing duck lips I don't care
Mars is back in the news because methane
was found up there by NASA's robot
called the Curiosity rover which sounds
like your tinder profile if you only do
anal out of town and now with the 50th
anniversary of America's first men on
the moon moment approaching on July 20th
there's lots of talk about space forces
and manned missions and going back to
the moon and on to Mars and please have
you flown coached lately we can barely
put a man on the surface of LAX I don't
know if Mars is full of methane but
we're full of [ __ ] we're not going
anywhere
Mike Pence said the stated policy of the
Trump administration is to walk on the
moon again by 2024 by any means
necessary
he he really used that for now applaud
you people applaud if you believe that's
actually going to happen by 2020 well to
everyone who applauded I have some
avenatti 2020 t-shirts letting go
for a very reasonable price folks really
America can't maintain our
infrastructure can't update our power
grid we can't get off oil can't even
secure our elections and we're gonna fly
35 million miles to Mars have you looked
at our math scores to get the launch we
couldn't even do the countdown you want
to find water on Mars how about first we
find water in Flint Michigan
I'm sorry but we're not the will race
you to the moon country anymore were the
I fallen and I can't get up country and
as far as this argument goes that we got
to get back to the moon to use as a
launching pad to get to Mars where we
really got to go because we're trashing
this place so bad we need a backup
planet here's an idea
instead of going Mars how about we just
stopped treating earth the way Led
Zepplin treated hotel yeah this is
something I addressed in an editorial
here a couple of years ago that if we're
going to spend the time effort and money
to make an entire planet sustainable for
human life
why not the one that already has air and
water and the right temperature and oh
yeah we're here well in this position
this position was deemed completely
unacceptable by a number of experts who
live in their mother's basement who who
accused me of being anti science I'm not
anti science I'm just a big fan of
oxygen it's it's my second favorite
thing to enhance
in fact it's easy to list what Mars does
offer by just taking everything humans
need and adding nothing no air no
surface water no heat no natural
resources no Wi-Fi which to Millennials
is worse than no air I would say let's
colonize Mars if we didn't know what was
up there but we do know what's up there
nothing nothing and even if it comes to
that and we do someday need a sidepiece
space rock why not the moon instead of
going all the way to friggin Mars why
travel tens of millions of miles when we
have our own desolate lifeless [ __ ]
only 250,000 miles away
I have more frequent flyer miles on
Delta it takes six months to get to Mars
and Mars and Earth are rarely aligned
for travel so missions can only happen
during a two-week window every two years
if you get in trouble on Mars you're on
your own it's like living in Puerto Rico
but we can get to the moon in three days
Amazon will be delivering there oh but
bill I know nerds I know I know the
argument you're gonna say but a Mars day
is closing length to our Earth Day
whereas a moon day can last 28 earth
days who gives a [ __ ] if you have to
live underground or in a [ __ ] dome
the whole time how badly would we have
to rat [ __ ] the earth before living like
that was preferable it's not easy to
live in this Sahara or the North Pole or
West Virginia
but it still beats Mars it's summertime
now don't you want to be outside I'm
gonna spend as much of my July vacation
as I can outside or I can do so many of
those summertime things I like but I
couldn't do outside on Mars like
breathing throwing a frisbee and peeing
in the ocean I love summer summer on
earth I scream summer on Mars you scream
you